[Musique]
voir la planète c'est un thème canada en
direct de montréal en fait du coeur de
montréal au centre ville de montréal on
est si vous deviez prendre l'autobus
pour vous rendre à montréal arrivé ici à
la station vous seriez tout près de là
où on se trouve l'espace qui s'appelle
moucha kaluza et pourquoi on est à
l'espace et le mois de l'histoire des
noirs et on est l'invité un des invités
enfin on est on est vraiment
l'impression d'être bien reçus ici les
choses évoluent rapidement
nous avions prévu avoir seulement six
invités je pense que nous avons ajouté
une sommes maintenant rendus à 10 et en
voici quatre pour mener de front cette
émission pour lancer cette émission
spéciale de tam-tam canada alors on
celui d'abord clair en ce1 talhouët
bonjour plaire alors vous êtes ben non
c'est essentiel de vous parler vous êtes
coordinatrice ou coordinatrice soirée
fantastique
alors là dites moi moi je dis on a le
sentiment de savoir ça fait des années
qu'on célèbre ce mois de l'histoire des
noirs c'est un phénomène particulier à
l'amérique du nord également un sou - ue
muni en le célèbrent un peu partout à
travers le monde nous la table ronde du
mois de l'histoire des noirs ça fait 28
ans quand le célèbre à montréal et dans
la région
comment la réponse des maisons
évolue-t-elle je dirais que la plupart
des gens chaque année les gens son envie
de savoir ce qui se passe les gens
viennent à nos événements les médias
soient intéressés on a des porte-paroles
extraordinaire des lauréates
extraordinaire on a des thématiques
pertinentes des activités aussi
pertinent qui met en valeur le talent
des colloques des communautés noires
donc je pense que la réponse est
extrêmement positive les gens ont envie
de célébrer mes tournées votre main vers
où malgré dix le khalife lauréats team
des lauréates invité aujourd'hui chaque
année vous cité en modèle des gens qui
se distingue des gens qui se voit qu'ils
portent plus qu'un chapeau quand on
s'engage personnellement qu'on a deux
passions on n'est pas arrêtée à la une
seule fonction dans la vie c'est votre
cas je pense aussi fait de plus en fait
je travaille à la table ronde du monde y
sont des noirs j'ai travaillé pour le
gala d'inès également j'écrivais aussi
pour une plateforme web qui s'appelle
agitatrice qui met en valeur en visant à
inspirer des femmes par le biais de
témoignages de deux blocs d'activités
banks et voilà mal car on va vous parler
dans quelques instants
on a beaucoup de gens à rencontrer avant
de s'asseoir avec vous débattre ensemble
de la l'émancipation des femmes noires
parce que c'est le thème cette année on
a choisi
je vais vous demander clarence
saint-eloi de vous lever tranquillement
pour céder la place à une prochaine
éviter que ce sera avec nous dans
quelques instants
autour de la table très très proche de
moi bien un homme avec un nom
extrêmement important si ce n'était pas
de lui on ne serait pas ici c'est le
créateur de cet espace dans lequel on se
trouve qui porte le nom de mushagalusa
si bien qu'à je viens vous avez
aujourd'hui je peux être massacré des
noms je suis j'étais le dans les tricks
remarqué mais je suis pas un truc et je
venais de tout de dation tellement
différentes que des fois faut ramer
aider dans la sonorité lennon d'accord
vous avez créé cet espace là ici dans
laquelle on retrouve l'expression
culturelle de plusieurs nations en
quelle année exactement l'espace ici
existe depuis 2014 donc bientôt au mois
de juin on va fêter notre cinquième
anniversaire
mais sinon moi même je travaille dans le
domaine des collectionneurs et
passionnés de des arts traditionnels
d'afrique depuis près de 30 ans parlant
des oeuvres d'art africaine s est fait
d'un marché que beaucoup de gens
connaissent moins bien par exemple que
le marché de la vente des objets qui
viendrait de nations comme les gp b 10
nations culturellement qu'on a des
objets depuis des traditionnels depuis
très longtemps
il ya quelques magasins à montréal où on
peut aller acheter de l'art africain
c est ce que c'est quelque chose qui
augmente en popularité
est ce que c'est un monsieur pause parce
que j'ai beaucoup d'art africain
personnellement donc c'est une question
qui m'intéresse je vois ce qui est
disponible sur le marché à ce moment
qu'ils sont disponibles mais la qualité
et on trouve des pièces disons qu'on
peut dire un peu de moyenne qualité mais
non les éléments ici de chercher des
pièces sont très très sélective et qui
ont un sens historique qui peut raconter
quelque chose et
sinon je peux dire un comme galerie
d'art africain ici
à montréal le justifie le seul on peut
trouver des boutiques par ci par là on
peut trouver quelques quelques heures
mais trouver des hommes qu'on peut dire
des qualités de collectionneurs de
qualité muséale
on est on est les seuls et on est roman
très fier de ça pour certifier
l'authenticité d'un objet ou d'un objet
c'est vraiment vers vous il faut se
tourner est-ce qu'on pourrait
sélectionner quelque chose ici je pense
que les caméramans vont s'ajuster
quelque chose qui pour vous mérite à
être découvert là parce que si on
regarde vers ce mulot la paix ici est d
art très ancien mais on fait aussi la
place aux artistes actuels vivent
souvent très jeunes dans deux
photographes
il ya patrick lopez qui est ici en
résidence pour trois jours on peut voir
donc ces photos qui sont là et puis il
ya aussi siaka traoré qui origine lourds
qui n'a faso mais qui a fait des fautes
au sénégal mais qui vit à montréal qui
nous a fait aussi ses magnifiques photos
donc ici moi je te dis toujours qu'on
travaille à la fois sous la racine mais
aussi sous les fruits et les fleurs
jardin d'éveil est donc là la racine
danse et des arts qui sont très anciens
qu'on peut voir ici donc demain mais
aussi ses magnifiques photographe photo
photographie qui témoigne du talent donc
des jeunes artistes aujourd'hui donc
vivant c'est bien merci nous accueillir
dans votre espace jeux gigot vous avez
parlé de patrick je pense le paie
toujours
comment ça va vous êtes accompagné aussi
de quelqu'un qui a fait le voyage avec
vous de la france il s'agit de
christelle onomo bonjour glisse-t-elle
oui pourquoi vous allez vous venez de
france pourrait arriver ici qu'est ce
qui vous amène ici ccc le mois de
l'histoire des noirs où c'est encore
quelque chose d'autre en fait depuis à
peu près quatre ans je suis tombé en
amour de montréal c'est ce que c'est
parce qu'on dit donc effectivement mais
en tant qu'artiste on est amené à aller
partout dans le monde donc c'est vrai
que je reviens assez régulièrement et
j'ai été touché par tout ce qui se passe
ici au niveau de l'histoire des noirs
notamment l'année dernière où j'ai
rencontré guy au forum économique de
l'histoire des noirs et il ya eu donc
cette entente 7
cette alchimie et on a décidé de venir
en résidence avec un artiste et puis et
puis en partenariat avec d'autres
artistes de france pour faire aussi
découvrir ce qu'on fait puis voir
comment réagit le public montréalais et
puis voilà partager c'est ça l'artiste
j'ai regardé votre bien d'autres
artistes de france vous pointer vers une
table à laquelle sont assises ou pas le
point vous êtes on va vous essayez de
vous parler un peu plus tard vers la fin
de l'émission
à quand on veut vraiment oublié personne
dans cette émission concentré de 45
minutes
patrick oui j'avais fait le voyage oh
oui puis on voit ces vos photos ça
l'or ont réalisé en collaboration avec
un collectif d'espagne c'est une partie
de mon travail que je présente car je
reviens sur ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure ou multi casquettes en fait
faire beaucoup de choses
je suis avant tout dj vide j'ai en fait
officielle d'une chaîne de télé qui
s'appelle trace urban en france train
oui la musique gnaouie trace urban et
qui est diffusée en france et qui est en
afrique également maire qui est
énormément suivi là bas et de par mes
déplacements en afrique de par me
tourner je m'oriente aussi à travailler
ma double casquette de photographes donc
est donc là où je vais j'essaie de
prendre des photos et ce qui nous a
intéressés avec le collectif l'espagne
c'était de mettre en avant aussi le
pagne africain le travers ces photos le
pen le pagne africain le tissu non la
wax vouloir raconter quelque chose
autour de cela vous intéresser aux batik
des fois aussi pardon le batik le bâti
quickscan et c'est un vrai drame
intéresse
moi j'adore vos couleurs parce que
j'avais moi j'adore les couleurs dans
les contrastes beaucoup à vous est
avérée dans le contraste vous exactement
pour remettre en valeur et le tissu et
les personnes qui composent
sur ces photos on a pris énormément on
appris la thématique la relation mère
fille en fait au travers que ces pièces
qui constituent la relation mère fille
sur certaines des photos qui sont
présentes ici et voilà sa carte d'
extrêmement bien avec le thème exact
cette année tout à fait vous allez fais
exprès comme on dirait bien sûr on est
suivi ces événements on a découvert
l'espagne qui ont ce thème de voilà de
valoriser
la mère la fille et puis voilà avec les
émotions que dans les planètes se sont
alignés pour que voilà ça corresponde
vous rester jusqu'à la fin du mois vous
reste un peu plus vous adorez montréal
donc mais là pour le moment vous allez
quitter
voilà ce qu'ils souhaitaient la place à
d'autres qui j'imagine se connaissent on
va poursuivre la conversation avec vous
idylle on va faire semblant qu'il ya pas
de bruit autour de nous on dit il n'ya
pas de déménagement vous allez nous
quitte et également pour amener chantal
chantal elle y chanter le chant des
muses est là oui je suis vous n'avez pas
encore de micro mais on va vous branchez
comme d'autres l'ont veut on va a lancé
cette portion démission on va essayer de
débattre ensemble de l'émancipation des
femmes ou si vous voulez parce que moi
je veux pas forcer les choses
j'aimerais d'abord connaître votre
passion et idylle des gens ont
certainement reconnu chez vous une
passion parce que vous êtes lauréate
vous avez connecter quelques par les
hans ont branché à votre émotion qu
est-ce qui qu'est ce qui vous passionne
bon c'est une bonne question je suis
sociologue je sais ce legs de formation
donc les sciences sociales c'est ce qui
me passionne la jeunesse noire aussi à
montréal je vis à montréal depuis plus
de trente ans donc je te fais un travail
communautaire personnel professionnel
avec la jeunesse noire de montréal
surtout
de l'ouest de l'île c'est à dire de la
petite bourgogne je suis issu du
quartier de la petite bourgogne qui a
une très très grande histoire
au niveau des contributions à des
personnes noires ici au québec
donc je j'ai été nominée j'ai été nommée
lauréate je pense parce que voilà je
fais un travail depuis longtemps comme
plein d'autres qui font beaucoup
beaucoup de travail c'est comment dire
j'étais étonné d'être d'être nommée
lauréate mais il faut faut apprendre à
mentir embrasser les accolades et
d'envoi l'a accepté les compliments ah
oui c'est difficile quand on est
toujours occupée à faire ce qu'on doit
faire là ça a été un moment dire bon ok
d'accord mais bon on travaille pas pour
les prix on travaille pas pour tout ça
mais quand les nominés et reconnu je
pense qu'il faut il faut le prendre
disons que vous vous intéressez beaucoup
la question des inégalités sociales
ciblons un peu plus encore parlons les
filles la petite bourgogne nous il ya
une histoire il ya des histoires à
raconter essayé de me faire comprendre
c'est quoi la réalité d'une jeune fille
une jeune femme est il ya 20 ans la
réalité aujourd'hui faire voir si ça a
changé si ça s'améliore ou pas moi je ne
sais pas j'aimerais qu'on fasse
découvrir montréal un peu de moyens
qu'on dit adorer
mais qui est de plusieurs couleurs bien
différent des n'est pas toujours des
beaux des boutons de raconter une
histoire ou deux breaks ont tenu un peu
ce qui se passe
bah c'est sûr que mon histoire est situé
tout à l'heure vous avez demandé si on
se connaissait moi je connais pas la
majorité des gens ici donc on est tous
très différents
moi je suis sur la petite bourgogne
comme je le dit et j'ai grandi dans un
quartier où il y avait un bassin de gens
comment dire une richesse culturelle de
personnes d'individus et beaucoup de
personnes noires issues des caraïbes
surtout anglophone donc
disons que en tant que jeune afrique n
que l'arrivée de l'est de l'afrique des
parents qui se sont installés une mère
monoparentale
si on veut parler des femmes qui
travaillent très fort j'ai été élevée
par une mère monoparentale dans le
quartier de la petite bourgogne qui
avait pas d'argent du tout mais qui
avaient énormément de richesse au niveau
de conduire l'éducation familiale est
aujourd'hui si je veux dire je le dis
avec une très grande humilité si j'ai
profité de bourse
si j'ai pu étudier à la sorbonne en tant
que jeunes de la petite bourgogne venant
du québec ou ailleurs racisme qui est
assez prégnant c'est grâce à cette
éducation familiale très riche
donc c'est des femmes qui élèvent des
enfants dans des quartiers qui sont
perçues comme précaire mais qui sont
très riches de différentes façons qui
soulève tout ce travail de bras
économique émotionnel d'élever des
jeunes enfants qui sont stigmatisés dans
le système québécois
je suis sûr qu'à lille se retrouve un
peu dans le pays j'allais vous poser une
question en tant que sociologue
forcément vous observez les faits de
société enfin d'immigrantes mère
monoparentale
j'imagine que ça doit difficile
et donc quand vous confronter votre
réalité par rapport à celles d'autres
jeunes de votre quartier
quelle est votre conception oui ben
c'est sûr que là je parle en tant
qu'individu et pas en tant que
sociologue si je parle en tant que
sociologue je vais parler différemment
mais là je vais parler moi il dit mon
expérience les expériences sont
différentes
parce que par exemple ma mère et ma mère
est prof de français
ma mère avait un bagage d'éducation qui
la rendait relativement privilégié
malgré son statut précaire jeu j'ai
évolué aux côtés de jeunes par exemple
qu'il n'avait pas de parents qui parlait
le français pour corriger leurs devoirs
si vous voulez avoir des exemples bien
concrets
moi j'avais des camarades qui ont
décroché de l'école qui avaient des
difficultés à l'école parce que quand il
rentrait à la maison il n'y avait pas
une compréhension de la langue première
parler à l'école est bon je vous épargne
les détails de la loi sans etc et tous
les ravages que ça a fait dans les
communautés issues des migrations
mais j'avais cet avantage là même si ma
mère n'avait pas d'argent
j'évolue est dans un contexte où il y
avait des personnes stigmatisées
de par leur langue parlée de par leur
faciès et bien sûr de par leur gens et
les femmes la réalité des filles
spécifiquement moi je sais qu'en tant
que jeune africaine dans un bassin
caribéen
je veux dire j'étais très différente
parce que même mes camarades noirs des
fois ne comprenait pas la dimension
africaine de ma personne mais on était
solidaires dans nos expériences
partagées de racisme donc on est et on
était solidaires au final mais on vivait
des choses bien spécifique moi en tant
que jeune fille africaine je vivais des
choses bien spécifique aussi comment
vous avez vécu cette réalité là parce
qu'on sait que le défi pour les jeunes
femmes noires n'est pas seulement celui
de la mangue c'est le défi de la couleur
et comment est ce que vous avez vécu
votre différence assez bas ma différence
raciale je dors toujours en rapport avec
ma mère et
l'éducation que j'ai reçue parce que
c'est ce qui a été mon parachute ans au
québec c'est l'éducation familiale que
ma mère m'a donné j'ai été renforcées
très positivement au sein de ma famille
mais ce que je dois dire c'est que par
exemple à l'école moi je suis allé à
l'école de la petite bourgogne dans le
quartier de la petite bourgogne et ce
qui est assis anormal
institutionnellement sécu nicole remplis
de jeunes au faciès comme le mien il n'y
ait pas de professeurs de mon faciès
moi je peux dire qu entre l'âge de 6 ans
et 12 ans je n'ai jamais eu de
professeurs qui me ressemblent toutes
mes professeurs je pourrais l'ennemi
chacune étaient des femmes blanches
québécoise qui enseignait à une majorité
de jeunes aux profils racialisées et ça
ça envoyait un message très clair à la
jeunesse québécoise noir vous ne pourrez
pas enseigner possiblement vous ne
pourrez pas atteindre ce niveau parce
que forcément le professeur qui enseigne
maîtrise donc si tous les profs sont
blancs 20 les blancs maîtrise ainsi le
message envoyé
donc j'ai vécu une expérience
extraordinaire est un jeune j'avais un
père qui était un peu comme votre mère
qui était et qui avait une tête et
j'étais coopérants fait office de coup
vers 1 et plutôt que de l'envoyer à
l'école française c'est à l'école de
petits blancs il m'avait à deux reprises
il avait séparé les choses nous deux
années là deux années-là l'école des
africains moi j'étais le seul petit
blanc dans ma classe grandes écoles mes
professeurs étaient tous des professeurs
noir mes livres d'école j'étais au
sénégal l est s étaient des enfants
noirs dans le mille livres d'école quand
je suis arrivé au québec j'avais 11 ans
c'était complètement changé tout est
différent
c'était quand même
un autre monde et essayer d'expliquer la
réalité que moi j'avais vécu à travers
lesquelles j'étais passé c'était
impossible on a tous des trésors de
jeunesse comme ça qu'on emporte avec
nous quand on est plus vieux qui nous
font qui font qu'on a on n'a jamais
quitté la personne qu'on était au départ
c'est la personne qui voulait faire
progresser les choses je me tourner vers
le temps file à l'iss vous avez
quelqu'un elle à côté de vous qui êtes
une révolutionnaire c'est à dire que moi
j'essaie de savoir appliquer les terres
parce qu'elle est invitée chez c'est un
beau une belle façon de refaire son nom
ses chevaliers à l'origine johanna
chevalier alias hannah chez donc je vous
dirai si riche mais elle discours est
très intéressant le magazine voire a
fait un article à votre sujet c'est en
octobre septembre dernier vous avez fait
des entrevues à radio-canada donc on
vous êtes connus et vous avec votre bon
sourire vos belles belles manières vous
rappeler à tout le monde que les femmes
pour quand on veut parler d'émancipation
de la femme faudrait aussi et en même
temps vous le faites rassembler les
femmes qui s'opposent se quereller alors
explications respectives voilà toujours
en fait juste pour rire un peu c'est
quoi que je fais donc j'ai une plate
forme d'une compagnie donc on a trois
divisions qui a communautés et cultures
donc plus précisément pour tous les fans
ce que j'aime le côté communauté en
caisse confesse conquête et on crée des
discussions pour hommes et pour femmes
c'est vraiment des discussions qu à la
base mais des femmes ensemble on a des
sujets et on peut discuter échanger ou
écouter qu'est ce qui est très important
et c'est vraiment comme ça quelqu'un que
j'ai un peu fait mon nom à montréal
et quels sont les sujets qui reviennent
le plus souvent dans vos discussions
j'imagine
on attend des sujets très différents on
essaie de rester avec les
sujets qui sont quand même dans les mi
temps qu'on en parle
récemment on a parlé de la com comment
je peux dire la féminité et de la fumée
toxique
c'est des mots que quand on n'entend pas
parler mais qu'est ce qu'on essaie de
faire c'est vraiment d'avoir des sujets
que comme on te fait poser des questions
c'est pas des choses que tous les jours
dans la vie tous les jours vous allez
discuter ensemble que ce soit avec tes
amis ta famille je te ra mais non on
essaye vraiment de créer justement un
espace sécuritaire entre femmes que l'on
te poser une question et ça te fait
réfléchir donc si tu peux pas répondre
tout de suite à la question tu peux
retourner chez toi et tu peux réfléchir
ajustements mais c'est quoi ma féminité
c'est quoi mon identité personnelle et
c'est donc vous le web vous intéresse la
façon de 2,2 d'aller chercher les gens
via le web et il ya le contact humain
qui parce que j'adore mais je pense que
le groupe mais si c'est vraiment comme
ça qu'on a commencé là un des sous
projets qu'on fait discussions c'est de
women power et on a vu quand les soutes
on est au québec donc pour nous ça a
commencé quand on avait comme le disais
tantôt avait pas de représentation
comment je voyais pas des personnes en
ligne qui crée du contenu pour nous puis
quand j'ai pour nous c'est pour toutes
les personnes de la diversité culturelle
qu'est ce qu'on a décidé de faire c'est
que option n'a pas ben on va le faire
nous mêmes donc ça a commencé comme ça
mais petit à petit on a vu que comme en
ligne c'est parfait c'est pas si facile
d'appliquer une photo d'ali partager
écrire des commentaires mais qu'est ce
qu'on voulait c'est justement de
rassembler cette communauté de personnes
puis de discuter en vrai que je trouve
que c'est encore plus concret puis on
peut rencontrer les personnes qu'on suit
en ligne mais pour de vrai comme
vraiment créer une communauté qui à
l'extérieur de toutes les réseaux
sociaux j'allais poser la question de
savoir c'est quoi le profil de ces
femmes là tu participes vous
vont ils changer ce que c'est davantage
des femmes intellectuelles des
entrepreneurs qui sont nominés vraiment
différent comment on a une belle
diversité dans la diversité donc on a
autant des femmes qui sont des
entrepreneurs des artistes des
professionnels 9 à 5
même les âges est très différent c'est
de 18 ans a à côté d'une femme qui va
avoir 45 ans et vont pouvoir parler de
quelque chose mais peut-être pas de la
même façon où elle voit pas les choses
de la même façon mais c'est vraiment
intéressant de juste voir l'échangé le
partage puis qu'est ce que j'aime avec
ces discussions là c'est que tout le
monde peut partager et dire son opinion
on n'est pas là pour juger l'autre
personne n'est là pour écouter et à
chaque vie à chaque discussion mais moi
j'apprends à chaque jour on apprend donc
c'est ça que je trouve vraiment
intéressant sur une question en
coulisses tu entendras loin pour
discuter
vous parlez de changer les
représentations
oui c'est quoi ces représentations et
j'imagine c'est des clichés forcément
négatif mais un rapport à la diversité
oui vraiment mais surtout moi je suis
que c'est pour ça que je veuille
appliquer ce que disait moi je vais
montréal ans je suis né j'ai grand amour
alors aujourd'hui ensuite 30 ans est ce
que ça l'a quand même changé mais quand
j'entends parler de montréal-nord tu as
tout temps ce petit stéréotypes avec des
gangs de rue et que j'étais rapide
moi je trouve que c'est justement on n'y
est plus on traverse une représentation
positive
c'est là qu'on va changer la façon que
les gens pensent et là comme à briser
les stéréotypes qui l'a que justement on
va partager les histoires de toute la
diversité camara l'on est même pas cher
moins long mais dans toutes les
communautés urbaines à montréal donc tu
es c'est pour ça que j'ai pour moi le
mot représentation positive et très
important parce que justement à chaque
fois qu'on va voir dans l'immédiat des
passeurs diversité qui tuerait 70 ans
stéréotypé donc c'est vraiment pour
prise et ç'a aidé il va falloir vous
laisser partir éventuellement parce que
vous avez un grand rendez vous je ne
suis aucune idée
alors c'était ou macaire et dit le
khalife le wyatt 2900 2019 du mois de
l'histoire des noirs qui devait nous
quitter elle va être remplacée par une
autre invitée c'est toujours des
peut-être un éviter on se porte
une surprise pour le moment on va se
tourner vers une femme qui est d'une
allure superbe
oui vous pouvez vous avancer oui papa
c'est alors à yann a auch une bonjour
cette comédienne on avait évité une
autre comédienne elle était trop occupée
moi je ne sais pas non je sais pas
facile et comédienne ou être comédien
non parce qu'ils m'ont va des appels ça
des oies en anglais mais moi je connais
pas je me passais par là mais je sais
c'est pas facile parce qu'on est
toujours ces histoires qu'il faut se
présenter on y rejetée on est rejetée
c'est pas facile quand on n'est pas de
la majorité est rejetée finalement on se
pose plus de questions encore parce
qu'on se pose toujours des questions
qu'on est de rejeter
comment vous composer avec les gens
autour de vous et la réalité qui vous
occupiez celle de dire ma passion c'est
d'être comédienne et je tiens à avoir ma
place
oui parce que au départ quand j'ai
décidé d'être comédienne je savais que
ça allait être difficile
et moi j'ai pas suivi un cas un parcours
atypique parce que au tout début ce que
je voulais faire réaliser
puis un de mes profs m'a dit mais si
tout à apprendre à réaliser apprend à
jouer parce que tu pourras mieux diriger
les comédiens et dans ton écriture tu
vas être beaucoup plus organiques
pourraient vraiment te mettre à la place
des personnages
donc j'ai commencé à prendre des cours
du soir en jeu d'actrice je suis tombée
amoureuse de métier et j'ai trouvé un
agent j'ai commencé à travailler comme
ça donc ma première audition je les
bouquets j'ai été chanceuse donc déjà
j'ai eu la chance du débutant si on veut
et par la suite bon il ya eu
un paquet de rejet madonna je faisais
des statistiques sur 100 auditions
je pense que j'en avais genre 10 donc 10
% le package est là pour moi est fait
pour tenir le coup ben j'ai été depuis
le début une grande fervente de tout ce
qui est développement personnel donc à
travers toute cette éducation c'est en
voie de développement personnel j'ai
appris que tout le monde déteste le
rejet et que le fait par contre de le
vivre de manière quasi hebdomadaire je
devais apprendre à deal avec ça sinon on
ramassera la cuillère à chaque fois donc
c'est d'essayer de trouver
qu'est ce que je peux apprendre de cette
expérience l'a tout simplement donc
parfois c'est c'est juste parce que je
fait pas avec le reste du cast parfois
la majorité du temps on ne sait pas
pourquoi
donc c'est à nous d'essayer de se faire
une philosophie dit souvent c'est que
d'alléger vos questions à poser la
question moi j'insiste là dessus
oui comment fait-on quand les femmes wii
noire je dois rejeter j'insiste sur la
question en fait on au delà du courage
et de la résilience
comment fait-on pour tenir nos coûts ben
parce qu'il ya quand même le 10 % ou est
acceptée donc c'est là dessus que je me
raccroche en fait et puissent se dit
pourtant lassé réalisateur directeur de
casting producteurs qui me font
confiance et ils me disent ça ça
encourage pas ce qu'ils disent ok
continue ça va te tuer tuer parce que ça
prend mais bon les chiffres sont ce
qu'ils font c'est vrai que au niveau du
casting pour les personnes assises et
c'est très difficile parce qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
moins de rôles et puis en français si
dans la description des personnages
c'est pas écrit noir on pense pas à nous
tout simplement
et donc est ce que le public ado se voir
votre discours parce que généralement on
se dit bon est ce que le public est
presque ils vont voir quelqu'un de
différent
quelle déception votre public à nouveau
mais pour être en contact avec certains
membres du public à travers les réseaux
sociaux
moi je pense que c'est pas le public qui
n'est pas prêt je pense que le public
sait exactement
dans quel monde on vit et puis sont tout
à fait prêts à s'ouvrir à la diversité
je pense que c'est plus certaines
personnes de l'industrie ce qu'on
appelle les gains qu'ils disent
aubin les publics est pas prêt les gens
des régions vont pas se reconnaître moi
je vais en tournée en région fait partie
des pièces de théâtre étaient les
derniers sacrements
on peut la tournée de toutes les régions
et c'est eux qui rit le plus c'est eux
qui sont le plus contents c'est eux qui
sont qui ont les bras ouverts pour nous
rejoindre donc je pense qu'il ya tout un
discours qu'il faut briser
présentement je voulais savoir quelle
heure il est parce que c'est une belle
question qu'on pose à sa mère dès fois
papa ou maman quelle heure il est quelle
heure il est 11 38 donc il reste 7
minutes à peu près des missions alors
qui veut prendre des sièges ici et
occuper la place publique
vous êtes les bienvenus alors je vais
dire maiana merci beaucoup d'être venu
bonne chance dans les buts hugo mais
surtout dans la réalisation pourrait
aussi changer les choses
merci beaucoup et puis à venez vous
asseoir tranquillement et puis on va
gagner on va à nash et c'est la fin de
la révolution pour vous les boules
vertes
on va laisser la place à quelqu'un
d'autre et ce quelques personnes qui
veulent participer ne vous gênent la
dérogation qui est venue la délégation
de france parce que c'est sûr à moins
que ce soit l'ambassadeur je ne sais pas
très bien alors vous me dites qui vous
êtes parce que vous êtes des surprises à
l'émission les gens qu'on attendait pas
mais c'est comme les grands super fan de
familles des gens qu'on apprend pas ce
sont toujours les bienvenus alors je me
présente je m'appelle basia je suis la
présidente du comité miss pagne donc je
suis venu ici pour accompagner à
christelle onomo et patrick lopez carmet
candidater mais miss ont participé au
shooting photo qui est verni cette très
belle galerie aujourd'hui moi je suis
curieux de nature mais spag oui c'est
hazard qui est un concours de beauté un
peu court de beauté oui un concours de
beauté un concours de
d'intelligence aussi un concours de
personnalités et de motivation nous
notre comité notre but c'est de faire la
promotion du pagne donc ce très beau
tissu souvent exactement exactement en
faire la promotion pour les curieux les
connaisseurs les amoureux aussi les
passionnés et aussi nous c'est notre
héritage moi je suis né de parents
originaires de la côte d'ivoire je suis
né en france
donc j'ai cette double culture et double
héritage et mon comité on rassemble des
personnes qui m'ont question aussi une
double culture et qui ont envie de faire
la promotion et du coup on passe par par
le times
quand on parle du parc juste une
question personnelle ce cas des couleurs
que qui n'existent pas parce que c'est
ce que vous essayez des teintures
naturelles
expliquez moi quelque chose à ce sujet
la couleur qui n'existent pas pas la
connaissance toutes les couleurs sont
utilisés même parfois
donc c'est vrai que là
traditionnellement le pagne du moins le
mot le wax je vais surtout parler de
celui ci parce que c'est celui que je
porte aujourd'hui effectivement et étant
donc maintenant s'est reproduit à une
très grande échelle dans des grandes
usines en hollande mais originairement
ça venait de l'indonésie ont fait part
par des personnes qui venaient du ghana
et du nigeria qui ont rapporté ensuite
ça en afrique et ensuite ça s'est
démocratisé en afrique et c'est vrai que
c'est plus particulièrement approprié à
l'afrique mais à l'origine celle de
l'indonésie
on va tricoter un peu on va avoir qui
votre la collègue ou de l'ami qui est à
côté de vous nous présenter alors je
serais vous présenter mes havas présente
les roses ngoy angie
mais dans la vie je suis directrice de
centre des femmes mais qui dans divers
année 32 alors ce sont des femmes
africaines qui ont mis sur pied afrique
au féminin qui est le centre des femmes
de bach extension qui à l'origine était
un centre pour des femmes africaines et
aujourd'hui bon c'est sûr qu'on reçoit
toutes les femmes de plusieurs diversité
j'avais dit qu'elle pose comme ces
problèmes généralement dans votre centre
est-ce que c'est toujours une
accessibilité d emploi le chômage le
rejet dans la société
c'est quoi leur problème lors de l'aller
les premiers problématique de la femme
quand elle arrive c'est vraiment son
intégration
et c'est ça qu'on commence qu'est ce que
le logement est ce que ces enfants sont
à l'école
est ce que est ce que l'escaladé la
nourriture dans ce sont vraiment des
services qu'on a mis en place pour que
parce que si la femme de chercher de
travail et qu'elle n'a pas où mettre ses
enfants
alors ça c'est vraiment un problème la
csc des femmes qui viennent d'arriver
oui c'est vrai mais aussi vient
d'arriver mais défend boutiques sont là
depuis longtemps et qui n'ont pas encore
publié leur isolement
ça c'est très important il faut vraiment
aller les chercher pour qu'elle brise
les os le joindre et qu'elle puisse
vraiment se familiariser à l'hiver à
l'hiver mais sont ils alors qu'en
réalité locale on est vraiment des stars
j'avais fait des études à nu ou hec oui
comme comptable il devient comptage pas
si c'est vraiment le site quand vous
donnez à l'époque quand on suit votre
diplôme et est-ce que vous dès le départ
vous dit un jour je vais me tourner je
vais avoir je vais créer un centre c'est
s'avère que je me dirige parce que ces
études ou hec
ça demande un investissement de temps et
d'argent
incroyable non vraiment c'est pas
quelque chose que je pensais que je
devais vraiment diriger un organisme
communautaire et surtout subvenir aux
besoins des fins est venu vraiment par
vocation
ça veut dire que j'ai vu comment je me
suis dit ok mais je suis arrivé dans ce
pays et mon intégration a été difficile
et là où je suis allé chercher de l'aide
j'ai commencé par part dû faire du
bénévolat à leurs aidants au niveau de
la comptabilité et la sous directrice
aujourd'hui mais c'est par là que j'ai
commencé j'ai vu un homme dans mon
moment cru que l'homme j'ai vus comme
des femmes qui arrivait et qui était
comme ok mais qu'est ce que je vais
faire qu'est ce que je veux je vais voir
d'où je peux partir
qu'est-ce qui est alors c'est ça qui m'a
beaucoup touché jeudi mais ok mais je
laisse mon diplôme de côté il faut que
j'entre dans l'intégration de la femme
immigrée
faut que je puisse aider ces femmes là à
pouvoir trouver leur chemin pour que je
puisse aider ces femmes là pouvoir se
faire de la place dans ce pays si faut
qu'on trouve que la femme elle est
capable dans le pays
dès qu'elle arrive elle peut prendre sa
place et il ya des ouvertures
allez-y et fait quelque chose n'importe
quoi mais en terme de bilan au delà de
l'empathie que vous avez joué au pays
vis-à-vis de vos semblant oui est-ce que
vous pouvez avoir le sentiment de la
tâche accomplie
oui je peux avoir le sentiment de la
tâche accomplie pourquoi parce que dans
l'organisme
on a mis un service de donner au suivant
ça veut dire que des femmes que nous
arrivons souvent et des délais de 8,15
arriver quel sens où je peux partir là
on arrive comme à la fin deux ans trois
ans tu vois une qui arrivent comme
avant-hier quelqu'un venait avec une
enveloppe mais distincts dont qui est
donnée par une que je connais pas que je
ne connais même pas donc ils n'arrivent
pas des dons nous donne aussi les dons
de vêtements samedi que les les dons de
vêtements aux familles nouvel arrivant
quelqu'un peut arriver dit mes enfants
sont là ça ça ne suffit plus est-ce que
vous pouvez les donner aux familles
suivants parce que c'est ce que vous
avez fait pour moi donc donner au
suivant cinq continents dont on doit
saisir l'occasion je suis sûr que
c'était des dons quel est votre adresse
mais notre hadès et aux 7000 avait nous
dit pas que c'est la suite 106 à
montréal québec
c'est dans le quartier parc extension
7000 ha du parc 7 me je passe par là
tous les jours alors je sens car hélas
un peu de temps bien sûr il reste un peu
de temps et j'ai en moi je pense trois
autres invités ont reçu une autre qui
êtes-vous
[Musique]
exposition commissariat par deux femmes
noires et qui mettait en lumière le
travail d'artistes de grands noms de
l'art contemporain et aussi de l'artiste
locale émergente ça avait lieu à
quelques rues d'ici à lucas exactement
bon là c'est fini un peu plus oui c'est
fini
radio-canada tu le fais des reportages
voire quatre couverts je dois voir à
couvert sur le devoir a converti on a
une belle couverture médiatique parce
que effectivement il y avait des grands
noms comme les années molly qui est
exposé à la fondation louis vuitton à
paris qu'a exposé au musée des
beaux-arts de montréal on avait shana
strauss également qu exposer au musée
des beaux-arts puis à côté de ces grands
noms de l'art contemporain
on avait des femmes ici à montréal
investissent le domaine de l'art
contemporain mais qui n'ont pas de des
spas sont exposées en fait
et du coup c'était important pour nous
d'avoir à la fois des artistes locales
mais aussi d'avoir des artistes
internationaux et y exposer commun de
l'uqam s'il ya des grains il ya un
espace public des grains de agora si
vous voulez oui est ce que vous étiez là
où vous étiez un nom était dans une
galerie la galerie d'expérimentation des
étudiants à la maîtrise en arts visuels
et médiatiques donc on a investi la
galerie on a par la galerie on a
réfléchi à la scénographie
c'était un travail de plusieurs mois et
c'est dommage du coup d'avoir une aussi
petite galerie pour une exposition qui
avait autant de choses à dire moi la
dénomination d'un autre exposition va
chercher pourquoi subalternes enfants un
subalterne ça vient du latin sous
alternance ou l'autre est en fait là je
reprends une phrase je reprends un peu
bête oups qui lorsqu'on parle du vécu
des personnes noires on s'intéresse en
priorité aux âmes noires lorsqu'on parle
du vécu des femmes on s'intéresse aux
priorités au vécu des femmes blanches à
quel moment on va s'intéresser au vécu
des femmes noires qui sont constamment
sous l'autre une femme noire je suis
femme je suis noir je suis fan queer je
suis femme qui vient d'un milieu social
défavorisé il ya toujours cette question
d'être sous l'autre dans la
considération de mon vécu
c'est pour ça qu'on a vraiment voulu
aller avec ce certitude sat intitulé qui
est particulièrement choquant mais qui
qui réflète réalité en fait elle a une
dimension féministe
cette exposition ce serait étrange qu'il
n'y ait pas de dimension féministe je
soutiens dimension révolutionnaire
il ya aussi quelques dont j'aimerais
souligner la la participation la
création parce que il a fait beaucoup de
choses c'est michael farkas président la
table ronde du mois de l'histoire des
noirs on va qui veut céder sa place et
le lui laisser le mot de la fin
parce que c'est bien là vers la fin de
cette émission qu'on se dirige à moins
qu'ils aient une objection ici il va
falloir terminer un moment donné alors
michael louie rester là ils veuillent
bien entouré
c'est vous le grand patron si j'ai bien
compris un n'en fait pas on entre dans
une relation à notre propre patron donc
maintenant très bien se passer
oui alors vous êtes empressé de branche
et c'est bon dans cinq minutes
nous allons quitter les ondes ça fait
c'est ça donc j'ai averti
la nasa va falloir quitter là moi je
viens quand même prendre les devants
allez-y prenez tout le temps michael ça
fait 28 ans 28 ans que vous organisez
les activités autour du mois de
l'histoire des noirs
ça fait 28 éditions que le mode histoire
existe besoin ça a été si on sait chaque
coup et non ses moi moi je suis
président quand même depuis une dizaine
d'années que j'ai été administrateur sur
sur le conseil d'administration durant
plusieurs années win qui est donc change
qu'est ce qui bouge
est ce qu'on fait de la polar est ce
qu'on est dans le domaine artistique
autrement à quoi sert le mois
l'or fait partie de l'histoire alors oui
on fait de l'armée ont fait parce que
après le mois de l'histoire des noirs
on a toujours les préjugés on a toujours
des difficultés
un bon emploi on est sur représentée
dans différentes instances au niveau
national à quoi donc sert ce combat
après le mois de l'histoire de ce qui se
passe c'est exact mais il faut il faut
il cesser les faits historiques sur
lesquels il faut se baser 6 puis voir
que on sort de de la forêt là on sort
d'une marginalisation immense les loi et
toute la loi toute la régie de nos pays
en amérique du nord plus lent ici on
parle du canada ont été conçus pour
dévaloriser le noir depuis depuis si
longtemps alors le combat de wii
continue et c'est pour ça qu'on on a
tellement darier rage puis on essaie de
rattraper le temps puis à des gens de
toutes les nations qui nous aide même à
avancer vers ce but d'être à part
entière comme tout autre être humain
dans ce pays mais il faut s'en remettre
aux faits historiques au fait que si je
vous dis que les noirs ne pouvait pas
être vendeur dans la ville de montréal
ou de saint john nouveau brunswick et
cetera ne pouvait pas avoir tel tel
permis ben on comprend mieux d'où on
vient que ceux qui avaient un déni total
pendant des centaines d'années et
graduellement alors puis l'on passe dans
le black faits sont pas en vain en plein
de choses dans play et ça facilite pas
si finalement et envisager le futur oui
on répond dégage même l'ignorance de
tout le monde y compris nous-mêmes pour
s'éduquer pour aller vers l'histoire
pour aller à vers une richesse
finalement et puis même vers une
résilience de ces personnes qui sont
venues avant nous alors le mois de
l'histoire des noirs sert à ça et aussi
à nous donner un certain sens de faire
notre place comme plusieurs l'ont dit ce
matin et pour la jeunesse ou la jeunesse
si j'ai bien compris on va pas commencer
à changer le nom de l'histoire des noirs
n'est ce pas non il y en a qui voudrait
que ça soit au moins deux victimes en
vue que le premier où c'est la journée
d'émancipation hockey dans toutes les
langues empire britannique puis dans les
deux certains endroits ah mais moi je
moi je me dis que l'un n'empêche pas
l'autre à et que les noix sont n'est
plus oui le moins douces et c'est bien
c'est l'été ça nous ressemble plus est
plus lent que même monsieur moi j'aime
bien le mois de février à quoi d'être
eux mêmes éléments historiques
un quoi tu as été choisi sinon moi d'où
on est trop dans nos barbecues boudanov
et 6ème édition mois d'août nous mêmes
on fait plus d'émissions pour l'instant
encore tout à fait tout à fait jusqu'à
temps que l'histoire des noirs soi-même
un peuple plus qu'un petit admis un de
plus que deux paragraphes dans nos d'un
même et ça c'est cinq ans dans nos
livres d'histoire à l'école alors health
a toute son importance parce que c'est
toutes les choses que tu n'apprends pas
à l'école 11
j'aimerais terminer avec vous vous
arrêtez vous êtes une lauréate cette
année il y en a combien ils ont des
douze mois alors on a eu la place que
pour deux lauréats mais il aurait dit
d'invités 12 noeuds vous avez entendu ce
qu'il avait à dire
vous êtes dans le combat quotidien c'est
c'est aussi politique un certain niveau
ça on peut jamais y échapper on y pense
toujours les choses ont évolué depuis
que vous avez commencé votre travail sur
le front utilisé en interne militaire
mais c'est comme le président disait ça
c'est l'éternel combat vont dire que les
choses ont évolué oui c'est comme un
train qui marche c'est ce que certains
comme ou et d'évoluer mais ce n'est pas
encore bon on essaie de voir aussi au
québec certaines révélations qui arrive
deux fois quand il s'agit vraiment de la
peau noire
que ce soit à la télé que ce soit un peu
de partout ça revient et ça refaire et
ça refait parler de la place du noir
dans nos maîtres d'un seul beau pays
que nous sommes venus mais pour moi ce
qui est important c'est de reconnaître
vrais mâles l'apport des noirs dans ce
beau pays qui ne semble pas ce que les
noix en apporte beaucoup mais sans être
reconnu alors comme on va reconnaître
vraiment là la place l'apport des noirs
dans ce beau pays que nous sommes on en
donne trop et tu trouves vraiment c'est
sûr que nos aïeux nous même et tout et
même nos enfants en donnerons toujours
mais est ce qu'ils seront toujours le
niveau que nous c'est peut-être la
question à nous poser mais aujourd'hui
nous sommes là comme l a dit et c'est
qu'ils sont passés après moi on est en
train de combattre en train de faire
notre place dans ce beau pays que nous
aimons beaucoup
alors pour nous est profitable de ce
mois j'ai besoin que ce soit reconnu que
ça soit vraiment reconnu que chaque
personne que ce soit à la télé que ce
soit n'importe où l'on puisse vraiment
nous parler je vais te plains pas c'est
une anecdote
dès 11 ans j'étais comme dans un une
petite réunion avec la ville de montréal
et je lui posais la question de savoir
mais pourquoi si vous qui décidez à
notre place pourquoi si vous donc
personne n'a pu me répondre
parce qu'il faut quand même que nous
savons aussi dans ces instances des
décisions des deux hommes alors mais on
n'y est pas on écoute et on termine à tu
penses que c'est on n'y est pas c'est
pas positif mais c'est ça merci beaucoup
merci à tout le monde merci d'être venu
à l'espace moucha mushagalusa j'espère
je prononce toujours correctement
et puis merci à toute l'équipe technique
qui nous appuient aujourd'hui celle de
radio canada
merci à lee chantal chandelle ces
questions qui venait de l'expérience
personnelle qui ont martelé les missions
aujourd'hui
merci à tous ces commentaires de
révolution s'est apprécié faut faire
bouger les choses et puis c'est tout
pour aujourd'hui si stéphane parent pour
tomtom canada à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]